the dolphins game over uh you don't need
a key play like that for the game to be
over the game's over the moment they
start the game
59 to 10 43 to nothing if my math is
correct and it rarely is that's 102 to
10 yeah in two weeks that's not good
yeah that's not good how bad are the
dolphins is that is your math correct
there are you sure 40 or 59 and 43 is
102 yeah you're right my math is wrong
did you thank you did you think it was a
different number i did yeah one or two
to ten
i can add ten plus zero though yes that
we've got yes ten points total in two
games against 102 given up how bad are
they horrible disaster
i mean i don't know
what you really look at on the roster
other than xavier howard right now and
go
okay i mean he's the only guy that's
kind of an elite player in this league
there's some good don't get me wrong i'm
not trying to disrespect everybody there
but they are
uh really underwhelming and the coaches
are trying to find their footing as well
i mean there are a lot of first-timers
you got chad o'shea's a first-time oc
and brian flores a first-time head coach
it just looks horrible right now and you
know they're they're tanking for tua or
whatever doing something that's
a new theory now let me hear this one
yeah there's a new theory it's not tank
for two it's tank for trevor tanks for
trevor tank oh and think about what the
browns did yeah they had one in 15 and
oh and sixteen yeah one in 15 to get
miles garrett right 016 get baker
mayfield yeah i mean if you take a
quarterback with the first overall pick
in the 2020 draft who the hell's gonna
block for him right laramie tunsil is
gone right so you're going to get a
rookie quarterback and he's going to get
destroyed yeah so
there there is a that this is so bad
this is so embarrassing this is such a
how deep is this bottom no one knows
type of a situation that there are
people around not in the organization
but people like who down in that area
where part of all this they're saying
this this is a two-year tank this isn't
a one-year tank well i mean it that's
dangerous if it is a like two-year tank
that's you're you're you're playing with
fire there because
if you go one and 15 this year
and then on the second year of this tank
job go 1-15 again this coaching staff
they're not gonna they might not see a
third year they might not see trevor
lawrence come in the building so you
know they're they're gonna have to make
some major adjustments in free agency
and draft and be aggressive to at least
give themselves a fighting chance next
year because i think if they lay eggs
like we're laying right now next into
next year and there we just go whoa they
can't even be competitive in some of
these games then the the the media
scrutiny the
the fan scrutiny is gonna be so much
that steven ross might have no no choice
but the the fire the staff it becomes
too much of a disaster so they gotta
right the ship a little bit here during
this season but make sure they give
themselves at least a fighting chance
for next year there are people in the
league who believe no matter what they
do no matter how it plays out no matter
how many picks they compile no matter
what they do with those picks as long as
steven ross is the owner of the dolphins
they're going to continue to be yeah bad
not that they're going to be this bad
yeah but it's not like they're going to
parlay a year or two of historical bad
into all of a sudden competing for super
bowls every year having a team that has
a franchise quarterback i mean they
haven't had one since dan marino right i
get it i understand the value of tanking
once you're out of playoff contention i
still believe that you should try every
year to get to the playoffs and then
once you know you're going to
six and ten who cares if you're three
and thirteen as long as your coach has
job security but you're right i mean
brian flores may be all in for this
because he knows this is what the boss
wants and i can't come out and say it
right but it could go so poorly that
when it's time
to to begin to build out of it yeah i
can't i'm sorry yeah it's you there's a
taint now right we can't keep you around
yeah that's the scary thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports